I grew up in tampa florida my family
were immigrants from Cuba not during the
castro era but before they worked in
cigar factories they were union
organizers and really a strong
commitment to family and to i guess i
would say they beliefs a class justice
the idea that nobody's going to give you
anything that you have to work together
with your counterparts if you're going
to get better schools if you're going to
have better benefits at work a better
salary health care these sorts of things
and that idea I think probably seeped
into me as I was growing up my
grandparents my grandfather in
particular who was a pretty radical
labor organizer in his a day talked a
lot about that so a lot of my ideas
around that you can't take justice for
granted but you have to work for it
really come from my family I was the
first kid from my high school to go to
Harvard I got up north on a dare for my
mother to apply to Harvard College never
in a million years I mean sir didn't
know what that was I'd never seen snow
I'd never been north of Washington DC I
didn't own a coat so I landed back in
about 24 years ago now landed in
September of 1986 in Cambridge
Massachusetts without much of a clue
about what to expect but um but rather
quickly became immersed in a new
community not one that was based in my
my family unit my extended family back
in tampa but one an fellow Harvard
freshman and other students who were
part of the real political community
that I became involved with in college
I came out I first came out to friends
when I was 15 in my junior year and I
school them to family when I was through
16 17 my parents um very good of Cuban
coming out you know I'm talking to this
guy that I'm interested in dating and my
mother's listening on the phone because
there's no privacy at all nor should
there be any expectation and then there
was an explanation I had where we kind
of discussed it with some words that
were loudly expressed and eventually we
figured it all out it took a couple
years but we reached our peace and my
mother and my father and really my
entire family has been wonderful in
their embracing of me as an equal
partner in our family experience
well you know I
been a Latino family I grew up gay
openly gay since I was 15 there did
they're alike in some ways and different
and others perhaps one of the most
important differences is that because of
my last name because of people in my
family who speak with accents because
the fact that we speak Spanish and the
food we eat and all these other kind of
cultural markers it is often extremely
clear to somebody that my ethnic
background is different than theirs and
then it's an ethnic background that at
least in the United States is called
minority and in many cases in many
places is considered less than being gay
is a little different you don't wear
that on your sleeve it's not part of
your last name it isn't in your accent
and so the first and foremost difference
is that you actually have to come out
and tell people that orientation you
have to invite people to understand that
you that's not to say that people can't
be discriminated against because they're
perceived to be gay that wasn't the
question the question is how is it
different and an important difference is
I have to announce my inequality I have
to announce to people my difference my
sexual orientation as not the majority's
sexual orientation which opens me up to
discrimination I was born subject to
that because of my ethnic background as
a cuban-american is a lot the email and
that's a very important difference now
in some other ways some other ways not
much of a difference at all I think I'm
a lot more understanding and empathetic
to the debater on immigration in the
United States because of my experience
as a gay man as an outsider I'm much
more open into and I think I was
probably much more easy for me to engage
around civil rights around the Equality
of lesbian gay families and lesbian gay
people in the workplace and in the
military because of my cultural
experience growing up in a blue-collar
neighborhood where I was raised with
stories by my grandparents and my
parents of discrimination based on our
ethnic background
you